ey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut ich habe
letztens auf ein Video reagiert auf
meinem zweitkanal wo so ein Ehepaar
glaube ich Restposten von Ikea gekauft
hat bei Amazon oder nachtige hä was auf
jeden Fall gab es das mal ich konnte
aber nicht mehr zurückverfolgen ob das
direkt von Ikea kam naja auf jeden Fall
habe ich dann mal auf ebay nach Ikea
Retouren gesucht so zwei drei Tage und
habe dann auch was gefunden auf jeden
Fall hätte das eigentlich 260 € gekostet
ich habe einen Preisvorschlag gemacht
200 € bei Ebay kann man ja halt so
Preisvorschläge machen dann kamen
Preisvorschlag zurück komm mach mal 250
€, die sind mir auf jeden Fall sehr
entgegengekommen der dieses Paket ich
ich hatte nur so ein paar Fotos die ich
sehen konnte da war keine Liste dabei
kein Warenwert kein gar nichts
wahrscheinlich also ich habe jetzt nicht
so die höchsten Erwartung heute muss ich
sagen aber ich dachte mir kommt das kann
man einfach mal kaufen vielleicht lohnt
sich ja ich würde sagen wir laber gar
nicht lange lasst mir gerne noch ein
bisschen nach oben da und Kanal
abonnieren nicht vergessen also ich
möchte ja auch mal irgendwann mal wieder
einen 10.000er mehr auf dem Kanal haben
wir stehen ja schon ewig jetzt bei einer
Million let's go so Leute hier haben wir
auch schon das Paket ach so haben sich
jetzt vielleicht was falsch drunter
vorgestellt also ich habe jetzt nicht so
riesige Sofas gekauft es sind halt
kleinere Artikel ich denke mal nur so
Deko Zeugs und so ich würde sagen wir
starten einfach mal rein ja ich weiß das
Paket fällt schon halb auseinander
übrigens hier steht einfach drauf
verstehe ich gar nicht wie das geht ein
Kilogramm soll das Wiegen das ist
völliger Quatsch dieses Ding liegt
mindestens 25 ich frage mich wie die das
so verschicken konnten aber vielleicht
gibt's ja einen Trick oder so
250 € bezahlt plus Versand was war das
Versand keine Ahnung 16 € glaube ich
schon auf jeden Fall jede Menge okay
womit starten wir ich würde sagen ich
arbeite mich einfach mal vorsichtig von
oben nach unten durch als erstes haben
wir hier eine
sodern die haben ja immer so verrückte
Namen Ikea ne also das hier ist denke
ich mal eine Badezimmermatte kannst du
vor die Dusche legen gar nicht so
verkehrt ich habe sogar so eine ähnliche
bei mir im Bad die riecht auch noch ganz
gut schauen wir einfach mal Restposten
halt ne home in made in China
was ist das ah ja ja wahrscheinlich so
eine habe ich ja schon kaputt gemacht
kannst du vors Fenster kleben und dann
kann keiner reingucken ne also wenn man
irgendwie ein Badezimmer hat wo die
Nachbarn halt reingucken können da habe
ich letztens so ein tiktok Video gesehen
dann könnt ihr euch einfach dieses Ding
hier kaufen und dann können die Nachbarn
nicht mehr reingucken das ist ja geil
ist keine Carrerabahn aber es ist eine
ja sowas hatte ich früher ich will das
kurz aufbauen das ist auch noch komplett
neu lilabo designt bei Hendrik Johansson
ich habe so ein Flashback ne wer hatte
früher das hatte doch jedes Kind hat
IKEA das jetzt einfach nachgemacht weil
da gab es doch früher so eine Marke die
so hieß die das gemacht hat ne und das
ist hier sogar so magnetisch Leute Alter
darum freue ich mich darüber okay ja bis
jetzt ich bin schon zufrieden das war's
mit dem Video danke fürs zuschauen nein
natürlich nicht wir haben ja als
nächstes Mülleimer alter das ist ja ein
krasser Mülleimer also der ist auf jeden
Fall schon benutzt gewesen ach und da
ist auch noch was drin hä nee es ist
glaube ich irgendwas für die Katze oder
little ah ja nachfüllkassette ach so ja
dann wird es automatisch nachgefüllt für
Katzen das kostet bestimmt 50 €, also
wenn ihr im Urlaub seid und eine Katze
zu Hause habt und ein Hund oder meint
wegen auch eine dann kauft euch hier den
little locker aber das ist das denn
jetzt auch von Ikea dann oder weil dann
müsste es doch eigentlich nicht little
locker heißen sondern Katzen oder sowas
wer weiß ich glaube das stand irgendwie
von Haushaltsware unter anderem von Ikea
so rum war das wahrscheinlich wieso geht
das denn jetzt nicht wieder auf ich
wette das Ding kostet über 50 €. okay da
lag ich voll daneben 25 na ja besser als
nichts das ist einfach so ein
Wischlingen so ein wischset also ne um
den Boden zu wischen ihr versteht mich
sicherlich womit machen wir weiter wir
haben hier eine Kerze jemendi dann haben
wir noch eine Cash boah Alter boah die
riechen gut oh Alter gebt euch mal die
Kerzen Leute die kann ich euch empfehlen
wenn ihr euch oft zu Hause alleine fühlt
dann mache ich mir jetzt immer eine
Kerze an die gut riecht deswegen nehme
ich die mit nach Hause so Spaß beiseite
Kerzen nämlich auf jeden Fall mit Harry
Potter Alter Harry Potter dir your drink
with the power of Magic Telfs Sting Mock
also das hier ist eine selbst wärmende
Tasse bin noch eingepackt ich weiß nicht
ob man das bei Ikea kaufen kann es kann
sein weil manchmal haben die ja auch so
ja ja da das ganze hier dein Käffchen
rein macht und dann ist es immer warm
eigentlich nicht schlecht irgendwie
klingt es ein bisschen kaputt aber wer
weiß ich sag 29 Euro ich habe sie
gefunden für Alter guck mal geil die
kostet sogar tatsächlich
41,33 €. wir haben ja schon mal einen
Teller ich sehe schon ah was war das für
ein Sound dann haben wir noch einen
Teller die Teller finde ich wirklich
schön Leute schaut euch mal hier die
Teller an eigentlich richtig weiße
Teller das Problem ist dass die anderen
Teller kaputt sind 1 2 3 also ich habe
drei Teller die heile sind und einer ist
kaputt aber gut hier haben wir noch so
eine was ist das da kannst du Warmwasser
reintun Tee so daraus trinken Problem
ist hier sind wir sind einfach so Löcher
drin das heißt dieses Dingen guck mal
hier da kann man sehen kannst du direkt
in Müll schmeißen weil das Wasser bleibt
nicht lange drin perfekt oh mann oh mann
ey wirklich ich sage erst am Ende was
dazu hier haben wir noch eine
Schatzkiste also ein paar Sachen kommen
noch und da sind vielleicht auch noch
Sachen die wertvoll sind das ist das
hier ja mal so eine Schatzkiste
was soll ich denn damit man ja Leute
keine Ahnung aber als Schrott kostet
höchstens 2 € oder so unterhalla ja
unterhalla war meine Uhr für Kinder eine
Kinderuhr okay achso ja ich weiß das ist
für Kinder dann können die Kinder hier
einstellen wie spät es ist wir haben
gerade ob ihr es mir glaubt oder nicht
hey Siri wie spät ist es
21:40 Uhr ich chille einfach um 23:40
Uhr noch in meinem Büro und Pack Ikea
Restposten aus so spät ist es an den
falschen lol was habe ich denn hier
eingestellt fünf vor acht so ungefähr
oder ja jetzt muss es richtig sein hier
pass auf tolle Uhr für Kinder einfach
Lego WTF ikea ist ja sind ja solche aber
warum seit wann haben die denn Lego
schaut mal hier ich habe zwar keine
Ahnung was das bringen soll dieses Ding
hier aber es ist tatsächlich einfach so
ein LEGO-Set oder ja wahrscheinlich Ikea
x Lego collaboration na ja keine Ahnung
relax days ach so kuchenset eigentlich
ganz nice Tannen das ist auch noch eine
komplett neue Pfanne finde ich
eigentlich ganz gut weil meine Pfanne zu
Hause ich mache ja sehr gerne Burger
meistens mache ich auf dem Grill
manchmal auch in der Pfanne die ist
ziemlich am Arsch deswegen deswegen habe
ich jetzt mal wieder eine neue Pfanne
hier haben wir dann noch einen ist ein
Spiegel Alter geil guck mal Leute echten
Spiegel den feiere ich ey den kann ich
mir schön hier irgendwo hinstellen und
kann immer direkt gucken ob meine Haare
sitzen das Dingen heißt Slim stop weiter
geht's mit noch irgendwas für einen
Kuchen da ist ja wirklich noch eine
Menge bei ah ja hier haben wir eine
Klobürste ey die sieht schön aus ich
habe natürlich auch eine eigene
Klobürste die ist viel stylischer Leute
checkt mal diese Klobürste die schön das
hier designt ist handmade steht da drauf
also das ist auch nicht verkehrt
aufbewahren mit nach Hause nehmen
Weihnachtsdeko ach deswegen habe ich
jetzt überall Glitzer ja vielen vielen
Dank auch perfekt noch mehr
Weihnachtsdeko oh nee okay und hier
haben wir jetzt was ganz anderes ich
habe keine Ahnung warum es da drin ist
aber ein Wasser water solutions von
Philips und das ist eindeutig eine
Amazon Retoure die wurde mal bestellt
von Herrn Joby John crazy Name Joey wenn
du das siehst schöne Grüße gehen raus
hier ich habe deinen Wasserfilter da
tust der Leitungswasser schon der Filter
das dann und dann hast du ein fresh and
drink keine Ahnung was das kostet 15
Euro keine Ahnung was das sein soll das
hier ist ganz gut das ist eine
Gusseisenpfanne und Gusseisenpfannen
sind schon teuer also wann sollte man
wirklich nicht unterschätzen schaut mal
geil also was heißt geil da kann man
halt so ja auch theoretisch Burger drauf
machen und aber auch Eier alles mögliche
eigentlich die ist kaputt Scheiße hat
halt ein kleines lag aber trotzdem
könnte ich die noch verwenden hier haben
wir dann noch so ein Dings
wahrscheinlich für ein Geschirrspüler oh
ein Klodeckel Backblech hey ich bin
voller glitzernde das kannst doch nicht
sein ach diese Tiere gibt's da auch
immer in so einem Ikea Laden ne gibt's
doch überall Tiere und ein Backblech von
Master Class oder nee Kuchen was ist da
die nennt man davon was sorry ich bin
leicht aufgeschmissen Master Class
roasting Pen 45 €, also man darf diese
Pfanne und den ganzen Dreck da echt
nicht unterschätzen das hier ist
irgendeinen Stoff irgendein Müll hier
haben wir noch ein Badezimmer Mülleimer
der ist kaputt das hier ist noch ein
Kissenbezug mega Bracken noch mehr
Teller oder was ist das denn ja ja das
ist was für Küche da kannst du hier
Batterien rein tun und dann sagt er dir
was für ein Tag ist wie spät es ist
Temperatur natürlich auch nicht verkehrt
okay vielen dank ja mal noch Lampen drin
ich hätte natürlich gehofft dass hier
schon auch was krasses dabei ist was
sich oder wo ich dann sagen kann okay
das hat sich gelohnt Elefant alter das
ist ein schöner Fund eigentlich ein
Elefant weil Elefanten und Baby
Elefanten was tun diese Elefanten hier
ey die sind wirklich zusammen der hat
seinen Rüssel einfach bei seinem Bruder
Elefanten im ja Elefanten hier haben wir
noch viermal verklar ach so das ist auch
ein ach boah ja guck mal ganz neu
erhaltenes café-set das ist nice okay
das ist gut weil das kann ich wirklich
verwenden für zu Hause nämlich auch mit
ein paar Sachen waren dabei die ich zu
Hause verwenden kann für die ich sonst
ja halt safe so wenn ich das kaufen
würde jetzt hier auf die Pfanne neu dann
natürlich die klobürstenhalterung mit
Klobürste drin da zahlt man in der Summe
bestimmt 70 80 € für von daher will ich
gar nicht sagen dass es jetzt so
schlecht war also zum weiterverkaufen
auf jeden Fall nicht geeignet wenn wir
noch einen Stecker und zu guter habe ich
hier noch eine
Klodeckel das ist einfach ein Klodeckel
habt ihr schon mal ein Klodeckel kaputt
gemacht schreibt's mal in die Kommentare
dass man dann zum Ikea fährt und halten
einen neuen braucht oder okay wenn der
jetzt schon so 20 Jahre alt ist und das
ist wirklich ein richtig gut erhaltener
Klodeckel Leute ja Leute also was soll
ich sagen erstmal muss ich sagen das war
nichts nein ich habe schon geahnt dass
das jetzt nicht so lohnenswert wird das
jetzt so kacke ist werde jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht gedacht also für
das alles 250 € ist wirklich ein Witz
ich meine die Fahnen okay die sind nicht
schlecht aber alles andere ich weiß
nicht wir haben auf jeden Fall da den
Deal ihres Lebens gemacht ich habe da
jetzt wenn ich es weiter verkaufen würde
keine Ahnung wenn ich Glück habe hole
ich da 150 € mit raus na ja gehört auch
dazu trotzdem hoffe ich dass ihr ein
bisschen Spaß hat beim Anschauen und wir
sehen uns hier die Tage wieder gibt's
ein neues Video und ich glaube das
nächste Video wird ganz lustig ich gehe
jetzt erstmal in mein Bettchen wir sehen
uns haut rein ciao